death stranding is an unforgettable
experience because whether I like it or
not I will not forget about this game
anytime soon I say that because this
game is odd yet remarkable it's odd and
more severe and critical ways like its
pacing and some elements about the story
and gameplay but is also comically odd
like the fact that Jeff Keeley and Conan
O'Brien have Cameo appearances and the
game does this completely straightfaced
as if that's an entirely normal thing to
see in a game but it's also remarkable
in all of those same aspects as its
gameplay and story are impressively
thought provoking and unique and those
comedic elements really make the game
feel like a game something that's wackly
filled with fourth wall breaks and
strange NPC naming structures as usual
the players to go through the story and
discuss what's actually going on here
and trust me there is a lot going on
here in death stranding but will also be
periodically taking breaks to discuss
these story elements to see if they're
well implemented so without further Ado
let's get started
I can't think of a better place to start
when discussing the Oddity that is death
stranding than first starting with its
intro first impressions are important
for a game I consider to be the first
two hours because it's still within the
standard refund period death stranding
simultaneously has an amazing yet
terrible first impression depending on
what you're looking for
story wise it shows incredible promise
and provides an intriguing plot
alongside a Mysterious World gameplay
Wise It's like two missions the game
starts with our protagonist Sam driving
a motorcycle through some planes death
stranding sometimes excels at giving out
information in a very natural way right
behind Sam is an upside down rainbow
that is Then followed by a rainstorm but
this rain is unique in that it ages
anything it touches as it turns part of
Sam's hair white and it kills the bird's
implants surrounding him when he
eventually gets to a cave to wait out
the rain we notice something is
following him along with there also
being some random woman nearby from
their reactions these creatures seem to
be hostile to humans and they also seem
to be attracted to sound which is why
they're holding their breath and making
very subtle movements we can also see
that Sam is looking at the footprints
while the girl named fragile is looking
up this is because she can actually see
the beings while Sam can only sense them
these invisible creatures are called BTS
or Beach things the reason these two can
either sense or see them is that they
have what's called Dooms Dooms for a
lack of a better word on our magical
abilities that do things depending on
your level Sam has level 2 Dooms so he
can only sense the BT's presence fragile
has something higher than two since she
can actually see them she's also able to
teleport as we saw earlier while they
talk we also see more of the time Falls
effects as despite fragile having the
face of someone in their mid to late 30s
her hand is that of an older woman so
adjusting timefall can have some drastic
impermanent effects The Last Detail we
learn is that both of them are Porters
fragile works for her own business
fragile Express and Sam is a freelancer
this gives us a pretty good idea of the
world of death straining and how
different it is compared to our own and
will continue this Theme by having Sam
pair up with Igor he needs help to
dispose of a corpse because simply
burying them in the world is not an
option once a body dies it enters a
stage of necrosis if it reaches the
final stages BTS start to go towards the
body the smaller BTS then summon larger
creatures these larger creatures have
what's called antimatter in them and
wants the antimatter of a BT connects
with the matter of a human body it
causes an explosion known as void out
and just one of these can level an
entire city so it's critical that we not
only get the body out of the city as the
resulting explosion would kill everyone
but we also need to get to an
incinerator so that the Flames can
destroy the body preventing the BTS from
being able to connect with it the last
and final thing we see is a baby inside
of a tank connected to Igor these are
bridge babies and according to Igor they
help him sends the BTS fragile doesn't
need one since she can see them but Sam
and Igor would need one since they can't
Sam's able to sense when BTS are nearby
so he could avoid them once he gets
close but having the bridge baby would
help as it uses the spinning device on
his shoulder called an Audra deck to
show the exact Direction it's in all
this once again is fantastic and adds to
the mystery of the world what are these
BTS and what happened to the world to
cause all this the game lays out the
information about the world's current
condition and also how Humanity has
adapted to it allowing us to see the
current state of the World At Large this
all goes in the complete opposite
direction though as while Sam and Igor
drive to the incinerator Igor goes on a
minute long spiel about the world of
death straining before the events of the
game it's Allure dump and while it's
helpful to the player Sam should already
know this he's been a delivery man for
years and has been on his own for a
while so he should be aware what the
death stranding is and what is happening
within the world Igor says that the
death stranding caused the world to be
the way that it is due to the world of
the living and the dead mixing together
he also says that because of the
constant threat of timefall in the BTS
people have been isolated and held up
inside the cities or in their own homes
outside the cities
Sim being a delivery man whose sole job
is to go from place to place to deliver
packages should know this so Igor
explaining this to him is pointless the
game also does this later when people
try to shake his hand Sam never shakes
people's hands due to a condition called
affenfosmphobia which is the fear of
being touched he also seems to bruise
easily when touched which is why he
avoids it this is shown non-verbally
multiple times but when someone tries to
shake his hand later they go ah right
aphen fossum phobia the fear of being
touched I read it in your file I
understand why the game would want to
bring attention to this detail as not
everyone has this kind of reaction to
being touched but I think anyone playing
could have sensed that Sam doesn't like
it the game didn't need to bring
attention to with their dialogue when
the cutscene does a good enough job on
its own overexplaining and repetitive
dialogue is a constant disease that
plagues this game and we'll see a lot
more of it as we continue getting back
on track though is the group makes it to
the incinerator they run into some BTS
causing the truck to flip the group was
also too late as the body necrotized and
was taken into the tar this causes BTS
to appear and take the guy who is stuck
under the truck Igor kills the man
before he was taken away showing that
death is a much better fate than what
comes next we already know what that
fate is though which are the void outs
Sam's able to avoid the smaller BTS
because of his blood for some reason but
the same cannot be said for the others
Igor ends up getting taken as well and
resorts to stabbing himself repeatedly
so as to not be taken alive before all
this he gives Sam the bridge baby and
tells him to get out of here Sam like
anyone though is in awe of the giant
beast in front of him which swallows
Igor causing a void out
Sam seems to be dead but then wakes up
on a beach he cradles the baby before
seeing a few ominous figures in the
distance and a woman in red singing he
then goes back to the real world before
seeing the destruction and like I said
one person can level an entire city so
far it's been an incredible start and as
his tradition with this game lots of
questions not a lot of answers but we'll
get to them in time the reason Sam is
alive is that he's a repatriot basically
he can come back to life after dying
using something called the seam Sam then
wakes up next to a man named dead man
who has a job for him deliver morphine
to the president of the United States as
if that's not wild enough already we
learn from another oddly named
individual die Hardman that the
president Bridget strand is Sam's mother
Bridget wants to connect all the United
States together she wants people to
connect instead of remain isolated
thanks to the death stranding she had
her daughter ameligo across the country
in order to do this but Amelie is
trapped and needs Sam's help she wants
him to do this because quote it'll make
America whole again the last time I
heard that phrase in alien race of
necromancer try to wipe out Humanity but
don't worry there are no markers or
Brethren moons here regardless the
president ends up dying and now has to
be cremated or like before another void
out will occur so we have to haul her
corpse all the way to the incinerator
once Sam does and disposes of the
president he's also instructed to
cremate the bridge baby or a BB for
short as it's been put on order for
decommission Sam refuses and ends up
using it to escape the BTS and head back
to the city this Mission then
transitions us into episode 2 which is
perfect as this was roughly the first
two hours of the game as I said story
wise we have a lot to work with we learn
so much information about Sam and the
world and all of it for the most part
will showcased quite well we're also
left with dozens of questions I'd hope
the player in which forced them to play
more if they want to find out the
answers the visuals and cinematography
were also just as great as the framing
of certain scenes reinforces the
emotions the scenes want to convey like
how it positions the camera by Sam to
show how large and ominous the BT really
is the game is also slow in this way as
dialogue and actions are spaced out
allowing you to release sit with these
moments and take them in such as the
crater it wants you to feel the pain of
this scene knowing that there used to be
people who lived here that are now gone
in a Flash it's incredible and hooked me
from the very beginning the gameplay
though leaves a lot to be desired out of
the 120 Minutes that make up these two
hours around 30 minutes of it is actual
gameplay that is a fourth of the game so
far all of the other 90 minutes are
cutscenes and I truly mean that I've
seen a growing rise in complaints over
the years regarding Sony games as people
describe them as movie games this game
with games like The Last of Us Part 2 as
well as God of War 2018 and Ragnarok but
while I disagree when it comes to those
games I can see the argument for it here
death stranding will space out its
cutscenes later and ironically enough
actually flip it on its head later as
there are times where you can go three
hours without any cutscenes or some kind
of story progression but as of right now
there's not a whole lot of time for the
player to really get a feel for the
gameplay all we do is two missions carry
the cargo to the city then carry the
president to the incinerator it does
teach you how to maneuver the landscape
which is nice but it's not a whole lot
these would be great as introductory
missions and they are but as I said
we're two hours into the game and a lot
more Mission should have gone by this
creates a problem those who want to skip
the story so they can play the game are
able to do more missions but at the cost
of the story causing them to be even
more confused and they likely already
are but on the other hand playing the
game at its current Pace means you miss
out on a lot of the gameplay the main
thing you'll be doing throughout the
game to enjoy death stranding you really
have to commit to the game for longer
than you may think and while that was
fine for me I can understand why others
drop the game around this point from
here though we enter episode 2 when our
tasks were going all the way to the
United States to a place called ajnot
city as this support Amelie is being
held captive along the way though we're
tasked with looking at various cities
and homes by plugging them into the
chiral Network a sort of successor to
the internet this is our current and
Main objective of death stranding finish
what Amelie and Bridget started by
linking up the entire United States and
then save Amelie when we make it West
before we embark on that Journey though
we have a quick history lesson as I
think all of you would like some answers
and as to what's going on and I
thankfully have them the world of death
straining was very much like our own
until the BT was discovered by Humanity
a doctor was performing a C-section on a
woman because the mother was brain dead
but they believed that they could still
deliver the baby when he touched the
umbilical cord he saw a BT floating
above the mother but because it was a BT
it caused the void out this was the
first instance of this happening so far
but because the cause of it was rather
unusual people began testing and
experimenting with ways to prevent it
from happening again this is what led to
the bridge babies after the original
void out there were experiments going on
in a secret facility in Manhattan this
ended in the entire facility exploding
thanks to another void out accident the
current president at the time was also
there at the facility so America was
without a president for some time until
Bridget strand became the next in line
her first act as president was shutting
down the experiments but eventually
Bridget realized that the BBS had
potential to uncover the secrets of the
BTS so she reinstated the project but
under the secretive eyes of bridges the
BB program though was not well received
by the general public seeing as it
requires EXP experimentation on a fetus
that comes from a still mother which is
why she did it in secret under bridges
the company she created the reason the
BBS work the way that they do is that
the womb of the mother facilitates a
connection between the world of the
living and the world of the Dead the
world of the living is our world the one
we walk and live on the world of the
Dead is just another name for the
afterlife and in between that is the
beach a sort of limbo area that connects
the two planes of existence to get there
though people will need to travel
through the seam which is what that
watery place we find salmon whenever we
die basically in order a person lives in
the world of a living then dies but
while the body is Left Behind the soul
is then taken through the seam and onto
the beach that person then walks into
the water through the seam again and
into the Afterlife we don't ever see
past the beach so we have no idea what
actually happens when someone crosses
over but thanks to various experiments
over the years we know a bit about the
beach itself and how it functions the
beach is a plane of existence but
everyone has a different Beach so while
you and I might be on the beach our
specific Beach is different the beach is
a manifestation of human entities
Consciousness and perception of death as
such everyone's Beach is different as we
all think and perceive things
differently it was hypothesized that
animals may also have beaches but they
don't necrotize like humans do so it's
assumed that beaches are a human-only
experience the beaches also contain
various amounts of fish and whales
because of the real world event called
the cetacean stranding this is more
commonly known as beaching but it's a
weird phenomenon where whales dolphins
and other sea life all wash up on the
shore and are unable to swim back so
they die in the land so just as the
whales are unable to go back to the
ocean anyone who arrives on the beach
can't return to the land of the living
to add to the references this concept of
death is roughly based on the ancient
Egyptian beliefs the Egyptians believed
in Aha and akka the ha is the physical
body while the KA is the soul the
intended process would be for the body
to die and decompose while the soul
continues on into the Afterlife but that
changed after the death stranding the
death stranding is the name of the
official event that killed the world
it'll be explained throughout the game
so I won't give too many details now but
the result of what transpired was
numerous void outs at the the same time
hundreds of BTS came from the world of
the Dead threw the beach and back to the
living they then made contact with human
bodies and then the void out started
many hypothesized that the BTS do this
because they're reaching out for a
connection as evidenced by the tar
bodies that touch you when you're
captured but also the various handprints
that are not only on Sam's body but in
the crater when a void out happens on
top of this timefall was also created
shortly after this event thanks to a new
substance called chirillium these gold
hand-shaped crystals are called
chirillium and its point of origin is
the beach when kyrillium enters the
atmosphere and interacts with regular
clouds it causes the rain to become
timefall like how certain chemicals can
create acid rain not all the water is
dangerous though as once it hits
something it becomes regular water which
is why lakes and waterfalls don't kill
you furthermore Dooms are also created
shortly after the death stranding which
gives people unique abilities Sam uses
it to sense BTS fragile can use it to
teleport and some others can even do
some wackier things the other ability
that manifested from this event was
repatriation which is when Sam is able
to resurrect himself so instead of Sam
going from the land of the living
through the seam into the beach he uses
the seam to go backwards and back to the
land of the living again
hopefully though this gives you a brief
understanding of what we're working with
here it's a lot of compelling lore which
raises many questions Chief among them
what caused the death stranding
throughout the game will not only be
learning about the present day plot but
also a lot about the world's history
along the way so we'll come back to this
event periodically but like I said
hopefully Now understand what's going on
as we can now return to the present
to refresh your memory we're tasks will
go into specific buildings like
distribution centers way stations and
other people's homes and connecting them
to the chiral Network this will connect
everyone together preventing people from
no longer being isolated and giving us
the means to share information with each
other through the beach due to time
being stagnant on the beach thus making
data transfer immediate connecting the
final note in Edge not city will also
bring us to where Amelie is located who
according to her was kidnapped by a
group of terrorists amelu led a group
called Bridges one they were the first
expedition team that would go from east
to west and connect America the same
thing we're doing now they made
incredible progress but were stopped by
a group of terrorists who took her
captive they want the world to stay
disconnected and also want the UCA or
the United cities of America the new
government to leave them alone and
Amelie is their insurance to make sure
their needs are met these terrorists are
called homo demons or Mad Men in Latin
which is a fitting name as they're not
afraid to kill people in fact they've
been known to intentionally kill people
in order to trigger void outs the body
that we had to take in the beginning is
hypothesized to be the work of the homo
demon seeing as one of them does show up
right when the BTS arrive also I figured
I should mention this Amelie is in the
room with us but she's using a hologram
the terrorists are cool with her doing
this for a very specific reason that
I'll mention later but I felt like I
should mention that seeing as I just
said she was captured but she's also in
the room with that laid out though we
can start our journey our first step is
to oh sorry hold on a minute
triple check your Loadout I take it
anyway our first step is to
[Music]
yeah death stranding doesn't shut up
sometimes this is that over explaining
problem I talked about before Whenever
there was something new the game always
seems to stop and force the player to
hear someone explain what the weapon or
item does it also loves to stop you in
the middle of an expedition just to make
you listen to people and fully believe
you are incompetent at times like when
later when we link up a weather station
this girl Mama comes by and says that we
can now use our cufflinks to check for
timefall and plan our route accordingly
die hardwin then gets on the comms
literally right after this to say the
same exact thing I understand that the
game is different and making sure
players know what to do is important
especially because it's not something
they can intuitively know from playing
other games like how to shoot in a first
person shooter but the hand holding here
is egregious at times furthermore the
names we gotta talk about the names just
about every character in this game is
named using some kind of conjunction or
reference Sam Porter Bridges is not only
a porter but also works for Bridges die
hard man is called that because when
serving in the military he was able to
survive against impossible odds because
for him dying is hard man Bridget seems
reasonable except her name is two words
combined Bridge it like Bridging the
world together she's also the creator of
bridges Amelie is surprisingly safe from
this until you realize her full name is
Samantha America strand which is just
insane not only is her daughter named
after Amerigo Vespucci the man whose
name was used to name the country
America but it's also just the fact that
the president's daughter's middle name
is the same as the country she's the
president of I guess you can't get more
patriotic than that I suppose I would
love to play a game with you if you've
never played death straining before I
want to see if you can guess why the
characters of this game are named the
way that they are before I reveal why
let me know how you do that being said
this isn't even the end of the absurdity
as this also plagues the other
lesser-known NPCs in the cities like
Jake wind owner of the Wind Farm or Nick
Easton leader of capital not city which
is the easternmost City in the game all
the cities have some kind of knot in
their name as well out like edgenot
portnot Capital knot and South not this
is because as Amelie says we're creating
a large rope from east to west that
connects the country together but to do
that we need to tie other ropes into
knots and connect them together so the
robe is longer this rope is the chiral
Network and the knots are all the places
we stop along the way to Edge not City
it is genuinely absurd how much Kojima
commits to this and honestly this didn't
even bother me at first I wasn't even
going to bring this up since I too
struggle with naming characters if my d
d Adventures are anything to look at but
I've come to realize that Kojima just
hates conventional names this is the
same guy who in Metal Gear Solid has
four different characters named snake
and a guy named skullface whose face
looks like a skull crazy I know when I
read reviews about death stranding I
heard a lot of people say that this is
such a Kojima game I think I'm starting
to get it now oddly enough this ends up
working stupidly well as I was just able
to remember one random NPC who only
appears in one location because of his
moronic name
moving on though we have our first job
which is delivering oxytocin to a group
of workers this is a great Mission as if
it's in line with the story making sure
the main quest is important as a top
priority for the story if the missions
don't feel important then they just feel
like side content and while death
straining is hit or miss when it comes
to this for now we're on the right track
oxytocin is often called The Love drug
as it's a hormone that manages certain
key aspects of the reproductive system
it's known to help with certain
behaviors and interactions like sexual
arousal trust and romantic attachment
among many others in the world of death
stranding people are isolated and can't
go outside due to a fear of BTS and
timefall so there's a lot more important
things to worry about than getting it on
as such the oxytocin we're delivering
will help these individuals get back on
their feet and hopefully not be as
worried and scared as they were before
as I said this is a great example of a
mission that fits in line with the story
now delivering a package may not seem
like a main quest Mission as most other
games usually have you fight dozens of
people by now but that's because this is
the main gameplay loop of death
stranding out of all the things this
game brings to the table the gameplay
was met with the most criticism at the
most basic level all you're doing is
accepting an order and then taking that
package to its intended location on the
surface it seems shallow but there is a
surprising amount of depth to the system
there are various hazards to watch out
for like water and terrain which can
make traversal a hassle you also have to
worry about the cargo and Equipment as
Fallen could damage the goods you're
carrying and timefall can destroy the
quality of the container if you're not
careful then you also have to consider
your actual weight if there's too much
weight or the cargo is stacked too high
then you'll start to lean and have to
shift your weight so that Sam doesn't
trip over and fall if the game also
gives the player the option to fly back
against the hazards you can use ladders
and anchors to ascend or descend a large
structure use pccs which allow to create
things like generators Bridges and safe
houses and the Audra deck labels the
ground with markers so you know where
uneven terrain is it's surprisingly
in-depth and provides a very fulfilling
gameplay Loop that being said I can
understand why people would dislike this
system Kojima wanted to create a game
about building connections and you can't
do that by killing each other death
stranding couldn't have been anything
other than a delivery simulator as is
how we first started as a world world
and as a country the first form of
long-distance communication was through
letters using carrier pigeons over time
this evolved into mailman which not only
gave rise to more jobs but also allowed
us to converse with people across the
country despite being a United Nation
the East and West sides of the country
were largely separate from one another
due to the long travel time even back
then it was still long as you could
write a letter to someone across the
country and it would take months just
for it to arrive America became
connected through mailmen and delivery
services so it's only natural that the
America of death stranding is connected
to those same exact means we're
basically repeating the same steps as
our ancestors and this is further
reinforced later in the game when we
start building highways the Lincoln
Highway was the first transcontinental
Highway that sent from New York to Los
Angeles and we're doing the exact same
thing with the chiral Network as we
start here roughly where New York would
be and then we're going to finish in
Edge not City located in California
that's more of a digital highway but
there comes a point where we build
actual highways which connect the entire
central region together the thought of
doing deliveries all day sounds
incredibly boring which is what leads
people to call this a walking Sim there
is a strange amount of community in this
game that can be hard to find anywhere
else this is due to the game's genre
which Kojima calls a strand type game
basically whenever you play something in
the game like a ladder anchor or even
leave a bike or truck laying around
there's a chance for it to show up in
another person's game if that person
likes the thing you place down then you
receive a like for it the more likes it
gets the more gets sent to other players
worlds before it essentially becomes a
permanent part of the world like this
bridge that connects the land to this
doctor's house someone placed this here
and gained enough likes to where it's
probably shown up in your game too the
game also has various systems in place
to basically have a continuous loop
there are shared lockers at each station
that allow people to take vehicles and
equipment for themselves if they need it
the players who put that equipment in
there are doing it for a specific reason
to allow others to use their gear that
they don't need at the moment you can
also pick up and deliver lost cargo
sometimes another person's cargo is Left
Behind and you can either bring it to
its intended destination or put it in
the lost cargo bin for another player to
deliver it it's this constant feedback
of altruism because we're all trying to
help each other so in turn we both both
get the help we need when we need it and
then help others with their issues for
example I had a few hermetic grenades
after a BT encounter but it was too much
cargo for me so I dropped off a few with
the shared Locker I'm not sure if anyone
actually used them but I can put it
there knowing that there's a chance
someone might need it everyone will
likely start out the same way and that's
using your own materials for their own
projects but once that one person helps
you at the perfect moment your mind
starts to expand a bit more there were
numerous times in a bridge ladder
generator or zipline either saved my ass
or cut off literal minutes of time from
my route allowing me to skip some of the
game's more hazardous sections I have
never forgotten these moments and they
made me not only consider my own route
but others as well this can be
incredibly easy to achieve since we're
all playing the same game it's like when
someone says hey man let me help you out
I've been in this predicament before you
helped that person out because you know
the struggle of being in that situation
this can be hard in the real world
because we're all living different lives
but in death stranding we're all doing
the same thing we're all journeying to
the same places and going through the
same hazards so these places aren't just
annoying to you but to everyone playing
the game even if you didn't intend for
the structure to benefit anyone but
yourself everyone is still doing the
same thing so someone is inevitably
going to cross the same path as you in
the central region later there's this
incredibly annoying landscape filled
with rocks and gaps which is why people
place Bridges and ramps on them so that
no one has to deal with how annoying
these hazards are you have provided not
only a convenience for yourself but a
convenience for many others and the more
people that use it the more likes you
get likes are basically the XP of death
stranding which I found to be rather
important for the gameplay because
they're kinda useless most games have a
super epic reward at the end like a new
gun or a unique armor set but death
stranding just rewards likes these likes
to increase some of your stats and your
overall Porter grade but they aren't
large increases the point of this is to
not do it for the reward but for the
benefit of others and making the reward
pointless further reinforces this idea I
don't have close to 50 000 likes from
other players because helping them gets
me a reward I have them because I wanted
to help people and there's no Greater
Joy in this game than logging on after
not playing for a few hours and seeing
your likes go up along with how many
people you helped in the meantime it may
made me want to help people more and
just be a better and Kinder person it's
the textbook definition of altruism
helping others for the sake of it death
straining is a lonely place and the game
really drives this point home by only
having you interact with Holograms 90 of
the time but doing this makes those few
times that you see a structure or sign
outside in the world knowing somewhere
out there in this Barren landscape there
are other groups of players fighting the
good fight alongside you all the better
it's ironic how a game that is designed
to make you feel alone also makes you
feel connected to other players in a way
I've never seen done before returning to
the story for the next five hours and I
do genuinely mean that we'll be doing
deliveries and slowly building up our
arsenal of weapons and equipment as I
said death straining is a very slow game
whereas other games get their tutorials
out of the way within 20 or 30 minutes
death Journey takes hours to do so which
means that straining is going to be
quite the long game and for the most
part it is during this though we'll come
into contact with two enemy factions the
mules and the homo demons mules are
other reporters who are so addicted to
the delivery process that they steal
other Porter's cargo before the death
stranding occur the world was quite
automated Delivery Systems are all
handled by Ai and the belief was that
doing this would revolutionize the
system however this ended up having the
opposite effect as people started
Contracting cases of drone syndrome
oxytocin and hormone imbalances convince
people that humans needed to be a part
of the process so they removed some of
the machines to allow for more human
interaction but this caused another
issue as people saw themselves as
Frontline workers they couldn't be
replaced as Society couldn't function
without them this then led to another
disorder called delivery dependence
syndrome this was further exacerbated
after the death stranding as timefall
shut down any chance for aircraft to be
used so couriers were the only people
that could get packages to other places
whether they liked it or not so people
took this Courier Obsession too far and
were addicted to the thrill of
delivering and the high that comes from
getting likes personally I think that
entire summary wasn't needed as the last
line is all that's important these
made-up syndromes are nice but I find
them unnecessary because it's very clear
this is kojima's thoughts on modern day
social media and how people crave
attention and likes getting likes in
game makes you feel validated and
appreciate the same way someone getting
thousands of likes on a tweet will make
that person feel validated and
appreciated but all things must be done
in moderation as over dependence on this
can lead people to go too far walking
through a sign or icon in the game gives
the person a like so you'll often see
people put these signs in places you
have to cross like the hallway leading
to Hartman's lab this allows these
people to gain likes that are actually
contributing to the World At Large even
though the game is all about doing
deliveries and getting likes players
will always find a way to game the
system but while doing this to death
stranding is not a huge problem doing so
in real life could have some drastic
consequences some people will do
anything for attention either because it
gives people validation or it pays their
bills literally just this week as of
writing this script some YouTuber was
shot while doing a prank video there's
this consensus that you have to go
bigger and better with every video and
if it pays the bills or gets your
attention who cares who gets hurt in the
process now a tweet in a YouTube video
are very different things but each can
be damaging in their own way fake or
stolen tweets are made all the time for
attention and likes and the mules are
representation of this idea they're so
obsessed with their profession and how
that they get from it that they'll
attack people and take their cargo to
play Devil's Advocate though they aren't
really bad people at least when compared
to the homo demons as they don't kill
you they only knock you out because
killing you would cause a void out and
they can't exactly deliver packages in a
world that doesn't exist this is in
stark contrast to the homo demons who
will kill you just to cause a void out
we talked about them earlier but we're
about to come face to face with one of
their members Higgs Higgs isn't exactly
a leader as the group has no leader but
Higgs is the most well-respected member
of the organization this is likely due
to his current Powers as he has the
highest level of Dooms in the game where
Sam's Doom level is at level 2 Higgs has
at least seven levels in it as he has
the ability to control BTS as evidenced
by him summoning one in front of us
foreign
[Music]
so how about it
aren't you getting tired of the grind
isn't this what you've been waiting for
this whole time
a game over
I find the placement of that last line
rather funny as at the moment I was
actually enjoying my time in the game
but a few hours from now that grind was
about to hit me like a truck before
Higgs summons the giant squid he tells
us that bridge strand is dead and that
Amelie has taken her place furthermore
Higgs calls Amelie an Extinction entity
which is something we'll learn about
later but its placement here is meant to
show that Higgs somehow knows a lot more
than we do especially since the news
about Bridget is top secret
higgs's name will also be the one you
won't understand unless you're fluid in
particle physics pigs is a reference to
the Higgs boson which is often called
the Higgs particle or God Particle the
first thing that Higgs says after his
name is the particle of God that
permeates all existence which connects
to the role of the Higgs boson in her
Universe the Higgs boson is believed to
be the particle that gives all other
matter its mass without it things
wouldn't have mass and the world would
be dysfunctional or more likely not even
exist to relate this back to Higgs he
sees himself as a god a being who can
control the world to his liking this ego
of his is likely because of his Dooms as
he's able to control BTS which is
unheard of at this stage to make even
more connections earlier we talked about
ancient Egypt and their thoughts on
death while Higgs is out of it has a
golden black stripe on the cape which is
similar to the color scheme of the
Pharaoh statues who's really taking this
God identity to the next level this
squid though is a required interaction
meaning we've come to our first boss
fight and it is less than Stellar death
stranding is not a great action game
because it's not one to begin with still
boss fights are almost a requirement in
games like this as they ramp up the
intensity and increase the stakes Higgs
is the main antagonist it'd be weird to
defeat him at the end of the game when
all our interactions were just us
talking like this fights need to occur
in order to solidify their role as the
protagonist and antagonist which just
goes back to the root of the issue death
straining isn't an action game most of
the fight sees the player throwing
grenades are shooting at it until its
health is gone none of these fights ever
really felt satisfying though it's
either me doing a hitless run for the
whole fight or I'm getting smacked
around because Sam can aim straight due
to the cargo shift in his weight while
these are important to talk about as all
the boss fights serve as narrative
climaxes to cap off an area it's very
clear that this is not a primary part of
of the game in the same way that hacking
mini games and RPGs are incredibly
simplistic as do not take away from the
real fun of the game so too is this boss
fights make up a small amount of your
overall play time and that's even
including the couple times you might get
caught and Trigger one on your own not
just the story related ones the game
even summons these white tar creatures
that are supposed to be other players
who will throw you weapons since nine
times out of ten you're not gonna have
enough equipment to fight them unless
you know ahead of time that's why the
optional ones you trigger lie to leave
the area stopping the flight entirely
and the required ones always have these
little guys throwing blood bags and guns
at you Kojima clearly doesn't want the
player to struggle in these fights EDS
is not a part of the game that they
should be struggling with having trouble
when planning your correct route is a
part of the gameplay struggling to kill
BTS Like It's Call of Duty isn't that's
why I'm not going to give these too much
[__] as from a sheer visual perspective
death straining succeeds in making these
fights feel cinematic and bombastic the
gameplay sadly doesn't carry to the
finish line but it's clear they were put
on the back burner since the traversal
of the world was the most important part
of the gameplay while the fight has been
playing in the background you may have
noticed a Red Cloud coming from the
grenades and this goes back to the intro
apparently since Sam is a repatriot his
blood can be used to harm BTS it's also
not just his blood but his other bodily
fluids a showering and going to the
bathroom rewards you with certain
grenades from your own fluids which is
as weird as it sounds these could be
used to kill all the BTS we've met
meaning these larger creatures and the
smaller ones we find out in the world
which adds another layer of depth to the
gameplay by giving the player more ways
to fight back against the hazards once
the squid has been cooked it calcifies
into this chirillium statue and then
breaks apart spreading all the kyrillium
into the atmosphere fragile then comes
by and Sam and her talk about going to
the central region to do that though
they're going to need to travel via boat
the central region is important to
fragile as it's where fragile Express
usually operates the business has been
on a downward spiral as of late though
due to some recent backlash unlike real
life the backlash wasn't about some
company running a scam or having some
misconduct in the workplace but rather
fragile Express killed an entire city by
outlying themselves with the terrorists
and delivering a nuke to the city's
front door now it is learned later that
fragile did not know there was a nuke in
the case but everyone else outside of
the company sees the express as
terrorists so yeah it's kind of a big
deal so much so that a lot of people
don't want anything to do with fragile
Express or the UCA for that matter which
then becomes a problem for us every time
we go to one of these weigh stations or
houses we use the cupid to link them to
the network but if the people refuse we
can't do anything about it since we're
trying to do things in a more civil way
or we're just as bad as the terrorists
there are quite a few Preppers located
here in the central region that we'll
need to convince that we can get the
network link to their property which
means we're going to need to run some
deliveries for them just like before the
missions need to line up with the story
in order to make sense and so far they
do these preppers are hesitant to put
their trust in another company
especially after what happened the last
time they did so helping them out and
showing that we mean well makes sense
each of them has different feelings
about fragile Express and the UCA the
engineer is comfortable with joining up
and doesn't take too much convincing due
to the long-term isolation they've been
in the other joins just as fast but
doesn't want anything to do with the UCA
since he believes connecting people
together is what got the city nuke to
Oblivion in the first place so he'd
rather stay out of it and the Craftsman
is against both and sees fragile as a
terrorist doing his delivery Mission
though does at least convince him to
connect to the network since we retrieve
one of his prized possessions from a BT
invested Zone each one of them has a
different opinion and differing levels
of trust in fragile in her business
which I liked but it just felt like busy
work none of these missions actually
addresses anything we never meet these
individuals again unless you deliver
lost cargo to them so they serve as
extremely long roadblocks for the player
to get over pretty much this entire
episode is just busy work the only other
things of note that we do is visit and
activate a weather station and then deal
with two other Preppers a junk dealer
and a timefall farmer the timefall
farmer is admittedly pretty cool as it's
not something I'd considered a toe was
brought to my attention since timefall
ages anything it touches crops that
usually take weeks or months to grow now
take seconds it's a cool way of showing
that in every negative situation is a
positive outcome waiting to be
discovered and how humanity is such an
intelligent and impressive species that
we always find ways around our problems
even if it means using those problems to
our advantage the other two though
aren't as interesting if I'm being
honest I still have no clue how to use
the weather station remember when I
talked about this game and how much it
holds her hand what got to a point where
I just turned off all the tips
permanently sometimes a pop-up will
appear on the bottom of your screen that
has some kind of tip such as using cargo
as a weapon or how you won't be able to
sneak by murals if your cargo's too high
these are are fine but they seem to
appear all the time whenever the
situation calls for it I just got so
overwhelmed that I disabled them
entirely which may have had the side
effect of skipping the tutorial on how
to use the weather station I don't even
know you could do anything with it until
I saw someone's playthrough where they
were going through a menu I had no idea
existed to be fair though it is also
entirely possible that I just skipped
through the tutorial myself because I
wanted to get through the repetitive
dialogue one of my biggest pet peeves in
general is wasting time and death
stranding loves to do this by repeating
the same animations every single time
every time you use the cupid to connect
someone to the chiral Network the same
scene plays again every time it just got
to a point where I was skipping it each
time it happened I've never pressed the
skip button this much on a first
playthrough in any game before and I've
never disabled tips or tutorials either
but death straining is really making me
tread new ground here now this isn't
really a critique of the game as it's
definitely a skill issue on my part but
there is definitely a discussion to be
had as to not only how much time this
game wastes of yours but also how viable
the weather station really is if you
could go the whole game without using it
and come out with minimal issues as for
the junk dealer he wants us to go get
his girl who he thought was dead in the
recent bombing but was recently informed
that she survived despite what you may
think that is not his daughter but
actually his girlfriend who ends up
proposing when they get together it's
really sweet and is a perfect
encapsulation of what death stranding is
all about reuniting people together and
sharing connections the two haven't seen
each other in I believe years and it's
nice to see them all happy again
although I don't know what Kojima was
planning to do with this as just like
every single person you deliver for they
email you about their life and
throughout the game the couple gets into
an argument cancels the marriage then
gets back together again what's even
more bizarre is that the girl literally
leaves his house to go back to hers
despite the walk being filled with BTS
and timefall episode 3 is probably the
longest and most drawn out part of the
game and is also my least favorite by
far remember how the first two hours had
more cutscenes than gameplay well now
we're going in the opposite direction
there are 20 main missions in this
episode which is basically the preview
these two episodes combined and it's not
until the final mission that things
start to actually go somewhere this is
around the time I started to clock out
side missions are nice as they break up
the pace of the main quest but sometimes
you just want to place the story to see
what happens the problem is that I'm
doing both at the same time I have to
blaze through these supposed main quest
missions to get to the real meat of the
story The pacing of this game is all
over the place and episode 3 is at the
Forefront of this problem to give you an
idea of what I mean there are 70 main
missions in death straining that are
split across 13 episodes Mission 38 is
at the end of episode 3 so just going
based off the numbers we're halfway
through the missions but barely a third
of the way through the game how is that
even possible 38 missions are split
across the first three episodes with the
other 32 being split across the next 10.
that is a major imbalance as one minute
it feels like you've made zero progress
and then the next you're going through
multiple episodes in just a couple hours
it's just all over the place and I came
for the life of me figure out why I was
created this way thankfully episode 3
ends with a bang both figuratively and
literally in some ways as it first
starts with us going to South Mount City
to deliver some Provisions before we
head out though a Bridge's employee
stops us and gives us another package
that was supposed to be a part of the
original order this is a lie as the game
literally labels this as a small
thermonuclear Weapon It's also the only
Cargo in the game to my knowledge that
has an owner history and we can see that
Higgs is listed meaning Higgs is not
going to Bridges to give us a nuke with
the hope that he could pull a fast one
on us like he did fragile it's a nice
twist I just wish the game didn't
immediately Give It Away by labeling the
cargo we're carrying I do however like
that we can ignore this and take it to
South not and subsequently blow up the
city the game instructs you to go to
fragile before going to the city but
doesn't tell you where she's located as
die Hardman already told you a few
minutes ago to be fair though there's
only like two locations she could be on
this map so it's not hard to find her
the suit will then open up the package
and discover that it's a nuke fragile
then says that we have to take get to a
tar pit near South not city as it should
be able to prevent the explosion from
expanding she's correct and after
throwing it inside we prevent the nuke
from fully exploding the reason she
knows this is because this situation is
all too familiar to her as right after
we complete the mission we get a lengthy
cutscene showing the moment that Higgs
betrayed fragile fragile tells us
earlier that Higgs used to work with her
and that he wasn't always this way he
used to be an honest Porter until
something changed now he's a terrorist
who's trying to blow up cities with
nukes around this time fragile caught
wind of a package and managed to take it
before it was delivered but Higgs had
planned for this Higgs then surrounds
fragile strips or to her underwear makes
it rain timefall and then gives her a
choice her time or the peoples see
fragile has the ability to teleport and
she does this by using the beach the
problem is that she can't take anything
with her and at this point in the game
you already know this as fragile allows
you to teleport places which is The
Game's way of canonizing fast travel
when you do this though you have to
leave all your cargo behind so fragile
either has to leave the nuke and let it
go off by teleporting and saving herself
or getting rid of the nuke saving in the
people but also has to run through
timefall in order to do so she hops to
take it herself which is how her skin
became noticeably older compared to her
face the only question I have regarding
this scene is the timefall as the intro
shows us that it can grow and kill
things like birds and plants but fragile
ran practically naked through timefall
for at least a few minutes and hadn't
even been 10 seconds yet and her skin
was already noticeably withered so how
was she not dead it's never explained
but I can only assume that timefall
doesn't kill but rather Aegis things as
far as possible without causing death
which is a weird loophole and doesn't
make any sense to me but I think a more
plausible outcome though is that fragile
had ingested kryptobites these worm-like
creatures are apparently not only very
nourishing but can also Grant resistance
to timefall assuming fragile's one-off
saying a crypto by today keeps the time
fall away is actually real and not just
something she made up on the spot this
would mean that she found some on the
way there since she clearly doesn't have
the room to carry any both explanations
aren't as satisfying as I would have
personally liked but the resulting
feelings that fragile has because of
this incident are something I did like
after hearing the story Sam calls her a
hero but she disagrees fragile actually
regrets that choice she wishes that she
just teleported and left even though it
would have killed thousands fragile also
doubles down on this mentality earlier
as when we talked to her in our room she
says how she doesn't care about the
United States or Bridges she just wants
to screw over Higgs which is why she
joined us in the first place she's had
an ulterior motive from the beginning
she never planned on helping us with
package delivery or any of that she just
wanted us to get back at Higgs it's
actually a refreshing take to have as
this whole game has been about altruism
and being good and here we have someone
who would have easily let an entire city
go to waste just so she didn't have to
suffer the effects of timefall it's
fantastic and is one of the main reasons
I love fragile as a character after
their talk fragile leaves Sam with one
task defeat Higgs and take him alive as
she wants to know why he betrayed her
that's going to take some time though as
Higgs is not going to be an easy person
to catch so for now we'll just focus on
the deliveries but just as I say that
we're interrupted by a storm the group
calls a supercell this isn't any
ordinary storm as it drags Sam into it
and once he wakes up he finds himself in
the trenches of world war one here in
this Dreamscape is a man labeled the
combat veteran who's actually named
Clifford Unger now anyone playing the
game should recognize this individual as
they've appeared in numerous flashbacks
throughout the game so far each time Sam
connects to BB a memory plays of cliff
and a room doing various things from
drinking to celebrating to talking dead
man says that people with doom should
not be using BBS as it's dangerous and
can also create feedback loops using
their memories fear and stress are
Amplified and the memories start to
bleed through from time to time dead man
assumes these memories are BB's the
thing is though is that we don't know
what Cliff has to do with this I'll talk
about the relationship between BB and
Cliff later but there does seem to be a
connection between the two as Cliff
wants our BB which is why he hunts us
the whole world war one era thing though
we can definitely talk about beaches
have the ability to change depending on
the circumstances for example Mama a
character will meet later has a beach
that she and her twin sister share
furthermore Hartman's Beach was shared
by a few others because they all died at
the same time in the same place these
World War beaches are likely the same
thing soldiers who all died in the same
place at the same time and also Harbor
the same thoughts of anger guilt and
rage these feelings manifested their own
Beach where the soldiers fight
tirelessly Without End as for why Cliff
is here well it's not a great
explanation but Cliff is a soldier so it
connects to his background given his age
though he wouldn't have been old enough
to serve in Afghanistan while also
serving in World War one so I think it's
more of a stylistic choice
regardless this won't be the last time
we see Cliff as there are three
different battles we get thrown into at
random Parts in the game the battles
play out like a Call of Duty level which
I'm totally fine with as the shooting
isn't terrible in this game especially
at close range but once we defeat Cliff
we wake up on the floor near where we
were taken however according to Mama we
were only gone a few seconds so clearly
time passes differently here mama is one
of the few people we've talked to
throughout the game and just so happens
to be the next person we're tasked with
meeting we need to meet with her instead
of the other way around due to her child
there wasn't anything too wild about
this I figured yeah she's a mother and
she's trying to work while also taking
care of a kid so naturally she'd be
Tethered to her lab I didn't think that
she would literally be Tethered to her
lab though since her baby is a BT Mama's
life is a fascinating case to me as is
filled with so many bizarre details that
I couldn't help but listen to everything
she said Mama is as you would expect a
mother but her real name is malingan
she's also a twin with the other one
being named lochna oddly enough they
were more than just twins as the two
were literally conjoined together when
born but thanks to a successful surgery
they were able to move independent of
one another but there were still two
beings in one body and thus had one Soul
meaning they share the same Beach as
each other furthermore the two can feel
how each other feels all the time it's
commonly known that twins can sometimes
feel how another is feeling even if they
aren't in the same room well this seems
to be the same for these two but
possibly to an even higher degree as
they use their Dooms to sense each other
the two from birth were pretty much
Geniuses and would end up also being the
creators of the chiral Network Mama
handled the hardware and lochna did the
software despite how similar they were
in both appearance and intellect though
they always disagreed when it came to
Children Mama never cared for children
as she was always engulfed in her work
but lokna always wanted kids the problem
is that each sister got a different
working reproductive organ mama was
incapable of producing eggs and locked
as uterus wasn't able to carry a child
to term meaning the two could never have
a child on their own this became
problematic for lokna as she fell in
love with an employee from Bridges and
wanted to start a family together this
was made all the the worst when the man
had passed away in an accident which
left Lochness suicidal thanks to her
Dooms mama was able to sense this
feeling in her and asked if she could
carry her baby to term for her through
some incredible Ingenuity by combining
the man's sperm and locking his eggs and
then having Mama be the surrogate they
were able to have a kid they weren't out
of the woods yet though and you can
likely see where this is going as right
when Mama was about to give birth an
attack on the city occurred and mama was
injured and trapped under the rubble she
would end up trapped on here for a few
days straight thankfully Aaron water
were no concern though as water was
dripping down from above the problem
though is that she came to this hospital
when she was ready to give birth so
naturally time had passed and she gave
birth here in the rubble but she gave
birth to a baby who ended up being her
link to the other side this BT is the
only reason she's even alive to begin
with earlier we saw some sort of ghostly
figure reaching out for the baby this is
assumed to be mama's soul her body is
only alive due to this umbilical
connection between her and her child as
such severing it would kill her
eventually she'd be rescued by Bridges
but was only able to leave since the BT
is bound to this place all the BTS in
this game never move from where they're
positioned they can creep toward you but
it seems like there's only so far they
can go that's why mama can't leave her
child as she can't be too far from the
hospital I can't imagine the amount of
trauma that comes from having to spend
the rest of your life during the place
that almost killed you I mean the rubble
is literally right behind her to cap off
this horrific story she also severed her
bomb with lockna likely due to the shame
of not being able to birth her child
properly I'm not entirely sure how that
works given it uses Dooms but we do know
that the feeling the two used to have
where they were able to sense and
communicate with each other no longer
exists there's a real depressing irony
in both sisters thoughts on children
being twisted around as Mama became the
mother despite not wanting kids it's a
real heartbreaking story luckily we're
gonna make things right although that
will come later for now though mama
wants us to take the cupid 2 Mountain
not city where lochna is located since
she and her co-created the device the
reason we're doing this is because mama
had a hunch that the cupid would
eventually become faulty and she also
thinks the super cell tornado that we
got sucked into may have been created
because the massive spikes in chirillion
we've been generating due to connecting
all these places to the chirillium
network given what we're told at the end
of the game I don't believe this is the
case but rather just Mama's hypothesis
this is a common theme amongst this game
where we're given unreliable information
from unreliable narrators it does make
sense in the context of the story as
there's so much about the world the
characters don't know so they throw out
random theories based off what they do
know it just makes it harder for the
player to piece things together
regardless once we reach the city
lochner says that she doesn't want any
part of the UCA or the chiral Network
for that matter so we're gonna need to
do some convincing such as bringing her
sister with us which means we'll have to
walk all the way back to Mama's lab just
to go back to where we are currently
it's as tedious as it sounds but
thankfully mama likes to talk during the
trip so it's on a complete drag once we
make it back to the lab though she has a
new device for US Gold handcuffs that
work as Cutters these should allow us to
walk up to BTS and sever their umbilical
cords giving us a way to take out the
BTS through stealth and mama gives us us
the opportunity to test them by having
us cut hers over the months to years
it's been since she's given birth she's
realized that the baby likely wants to
cross over and not be Tethered to the
world like it is now but doing so would
kill her and she didn't want to let
lachna down as this was supposed to be
her child but she realized that's not
right so the plan is to cut her cord and
then take her to see lochna this will
eventually kill her but thankfully due
to her already being dead she doesn't
necrotize like the other bodies do so
there's no need to incinerate her I
really like the detail here of Sam
asking Mama if she's alright with being
zipped up since her being constricted
like this is just like when she was
trapped under the rubble just goes to
show how much Sam cares about her
well-being two bad Higgs is here to ruin
the fun and summon a BT now I don't know
what was wrong with the wires in my
brain at this point but after hearing
Mama tell me to run and then hearing
Higgs say he was gonna tweak the rules a
bit my first thought was not to run but
rather take the thing head on with Mama
on my back this not only killed me but
also hurt Mama quite a bit thankfully
she can join him in the hot springs and
regain her health these are spread out
throughout the map and regain some of
Sam's Health and stamina while also
giving you a chance to watch BB swim but
it's also possible to have your human
cargo join you which is a really cool
detail some people might not know once
we take Mama to the city locking on her
get a few minutes to talk before Mama
passes away Machina is disappointed in
herself as she thought Mama cut off the
connection to her intentionally said she
could steal her baby when that obviously
wasn't the case from Locker though we
also learned that something was wrong
within the code of the Cupid lachana
assumes that someone tampered with it
somehow and given that these two are the
Geniuses that made it it's not hard to
assume that Mama intentionally tampered
with it so she had a reason to go see
her sister again it might seem strange
to do this instead of just you know
going to see her but Mama couldn't leave
without killing herself and the child so
she would have needed someone to assist
her anyway sometimes people are so
wrapped up in a predicament or mentality
that an outside force is the only way to
get them to snap out of it and thanks to
Sam the sisters were able to come
together again in more ways than one
actually as we see one of lochna's eyes
changed to Blue the same color as Mama's
meaning the sisters are back to their
original form the one they had when they
were born one mind one body can join
forever Mama's story is an incredibly
sweet tale and one of my favorites in
the game it might seem rather pointless
to solve this conundrum between these
two sisters when we have a world to
connect but just like with the earlier
couple this is what death straining is
all about connecting people together
these missions are much different than
the ones we did earlier because those
characters are insignificant to the
overall story and we aren't really
connecting them to anyone except the
network with mama she was able to see
her own sister again and also come to
terms of her condition as right before
we cut her cord she says you have to
break some ties to forge others it's
sort of like saying when one door closes
another opens sometimes ending things
opens up the opportunity to start other
things and Mama severing her connection
with her baby gave her the chance to
move on and reconnect with her sister
again
hauling a corpse from one side of the
map to the other takes a lot of work out
of you which is why Sam takes a rest in
his private quarters until he realizes
that BB's gone dead man took it because
something's up BBS are only able to be
in service for a short time due to their
age BBS are still fetuses but after
enough time they start to get older and
become an actual living being this is a
problem as the BBS are designed to be
Bridges between the world of the dead
and the living so them being actual
children would mean they lose their
ability to function as intended Sam and
luckily the player are starting to get
worried as they've likely grown attached
to BB seeing as they're the sole reason
they can cross the BT zones to begin
with to save BB dead man needs to
perform some surgery in order to realign
it but that's going to take some time as
will be without it for a while one very
interesting detail that comes out during
this scene though is that dead man says
that doing the surgery might erase some
of bibi's memories to which Sam responds
wait so Lou's gonna forget about me up
until this point Sam has never said the
name Lou or even mentioned that he named
the BB this is foreshadowing for later
so keep that in mind still though we're
gonna be without Lou for a while which
sucks a lot this Trope is very common in
games where players are forced to fight
without inability or their entire
inventory and it's the same here for
death straining it just so happens to be
one of the most important pieces in our
Arsenal and you know the game is going
to throw lots of BTS at you just to
hammer home how vital Lou is to the team
Dwight insult to injury the game also
ramps up the difficulty by having you
Trek through the mountains which are
steep covered in snow and walking
through a drains or stamina fast while I
absolutely hated going through it at the
time now that I finished the game I can
say that I at least appreciate the spike
in difficulty this area provided before
we can head out though we joined dead
men in the shower for some alone time
it's not the alone time you're thinking
of given Sam riddy struggles enough with
just touching people but rather some
actual alone time as the showers are the
only places they can't be monitored and
dead man has some information for us he
repeats what we talked about a few
minutes ago regarding Bridges and the
secret BB experiments but he adds that
Bridget wanted to also make the BB's not
just BT detectors but also objects that
connect to the chiral Network in an
attempt to facilitate travel to the
beach this never worked though and after
some time the terrorists retrieve their
own BBS which is why Higgs has one
despite not being employed by Bridges
seeing his dihardwin is the director of
bridges he must have had some kind of
involvement in this or at the very least
knew what was going on but dead man has
turned up nothing and that's what scares
him he doesn't even know his real claim
and has never seen his face before so he
thinks he has something to hide this
like a lot of info and death training is
something that we'll be explained later
towards the final hours of the game so
we'll Circle back to this at the end
getting back to the task at hand we're
told by die Hardman to link up more
Preppers in the area and we're also told
that there's a giant tar belt
surrounding ajinot City so getting
through there is going to be a problem
more importantly though more Preppers
means more busy work and it's arguably
worse here since all of them joined
without any issue except the Mountaineer
he wants us to travel to a doctor so we
can get him a medical device for his
wife this is all that's needed to link
up the final prepper so I must ask if
they left the UCA to live on their own
why are they this adamant about going
back die Hardman makes it seem like
getting these people back on our side is
going to be difficult admittedly it's
rather merciful that it's not given how
pointless these missions are but it
doesn't make the game any less
interesting talking to and linking up
these people doesn't further the plot
and it sucks to have to go from a
stellar Quest like Mama's to more of
this right after
it's not that they needed to have a
central part of the plot like our main
cast for it to matter but the missions
don't solve anything or answer questions
the earlier Mission with the oxytocin
was connected to the world of death
straining given these Preppers their
packages isn't in the grand scheme of
things technically everything we do is
furthering The Narrative as the chiral
network is not only being shared to
these individuals but their own works
are being added to it too so everyone is
benefiting from it still though it's not
something we ever see nor is it
something I feel is important even if
the game says that it is where things
start to get interesting though is when
we get introduced to the photographer
she claims that her father had a camera
with some pictures on it that could
prove vital to our investigations to the
death stranding on the camera is images
of a cave painting from the Neanderthals
and one of the paintings is that of a
dolphin Harman hypothesizes that because
the cave this was from was nowhere near
the coastline the Neanderthals didn't
run into Dolphins but rather be teas and
assuming that this is true this means
that the death straining is not the
first of its kind Hartman further states
that the death straining may have also
been the cause of the big five the big 5
are the five mass extinctions that have
happened in our own world the one most
commonly known is the dinosaurs who are
wiped up by an asteroid Hartman has a
theory that the death straining was the
cause of these five mass extinctions I
say Theory but he's correct just about
everything that comes out of his mouth
is correct which isn't out of character
since he is a beach expert but still
it's a bit strange how a lot of the
mystery is solved almost immediately
thanks to Hartman spelling it out for us
thanks to his so-called theories always
being facts it's very clear that Kojima
is speaking to us through Hartman and it
can be a bit bothersome at times this
isn't even the only character he does
this to as this Aaron Hill person emails
you to talk about Mama's unique Audra
deck and how it reminds him of a fallen
angel like the one who followed
Beelzebub down to Egypt and my first
thought was who the hell are you and how
did you get my email some of the
characters in this game are either
vessels for Kojima or become possessed
by him for a short time and it's not
hard to notice once you start looking
after a few more deliveries dead man
comes by and talks about Lou and says to
meet at a specific location once we
arrive though we're sucked into another
supercell but this time from World War
II I will say while Higgs is really good
at making an entrance verbally Cliff is
the same but for the exact opposite
reason you just can't help but get hyped
whenever he appears on screen even if
his whole plan is to kill you and take
Lou before we defeat Cliff though we
need to find dead man and Luke who are
inside one of the sewer systems this
near-death experience allows dead man to
open up to Sam giving us a chance to
learn more about him he opens up maybe a
bit too much though as not only does he
Share info with us about himself but
also about Sam's backstory which is not
a pleasant one to say the least for dead
man he is called that not because he's
fascinated with the dead although that
is part of it but rather he's an actual
Frankenstein monster dead man was born
via in vitro fertilization meaning he's
a test tube baby except the sperm donors
are unknown and the womb is artificial
so by technicality he was never born in
the traditional sense furthermore some
of his organs didn't function as
intended or were just simply missing so
the doctors took them from other donors
whereas I can personally say that my
body is my own as I've never had a
transplant of any kind the same cannot
be said for dead man everything that's a
part of him is not his own from his
organs to even his own birth which is
why his name is dead man as he was never
truly alive to begin with as such given
the nature of the beach he can't visit
one as he doesn't have one having one
means you have a soul that will pass on
to the beach but dead man has no soul
just a body a body that isn't even his
to begin with due to being artificial
dead man never had any parents and he
also struggled to make friends that is
until Sam came along as he's the only
one to have built a connection with him
which is why he was comfortable sharing
that information but of course now that
their friends it's only fair that the
first thing dead man does is repeat all
of Sam's history to us and make him
relive one of the worst days of his life
dead man looked into the archives and
discovered why Sam named as Bibi Lou It
Feels So unnatural to get this
information this way it felt like it
would have just been better for Sam to
say it instead of dead man that being
said though the info is quite important
as it gives us a lot of context
regarding Sam's departure from Bridges
and his hatred for America Sam's birth
is something we'll have to talk about
later but I'll just say that Bridget is
not his biological mother yet she still
took care of him as if he was her own as
Sam got older he started reappearing on
the beach constantly and ended up
manifesting those Doom abilities of his
being a child he had no idea what was
going on which is why Amelie would
comfort him as much as possible while on
the beach this is also around the time
he contracted that athenophosm phobia so
Bridget recommended he see a therapist
to his name Lucy Lucy is a sort of
atheist in the sense as she doesn't
believe in the beach she knows that BT's
Dooms and repatriots exist but the beach
is something she sees as a collective
delusion a way for Humanity to explain
what these New Creations are strange
that she draws the line there of all
places but regardless she was tasked
with helping Sam come to terms with his
condition and possibly overcome it Lucy
assumed that a lot of this stem from
Amelie and she theorizes that if they
distance themselves he might overcome
this resistance to his physical touch
Sam lashed out at her for this comment
but instead of backing down she went
further and told him that the beach was
fictional and that his repatriation was
just a way for him to explain his
near-death experiences that he's had
instead of getting angry though he
remained quiet for the rest of the
session as she feared that she may have
pushed him too far well she did as the
next time that they meet Sam seems
determined to prove her wrong by
committing suicide in her office to show
that he can return from the beach this
of course convinces her and is also what
made Sam break down as he's always
wanted to talk about this with someone
who understand and accept him that isn't
Bridget or Amelie and since Lucy was his
therapist someone whose job is to listen
to him he developed a connection with
her they also ended up holding hands
after he woke up and he never pulled
away and they both realized that they
share a connection with each other
thanks to Lucy Sam was not only able to
cure his affenfasm phobia but he was
also able to start a family the couple
was going to have a daughter who Sam
named Luis or Lou for short but as she
got closer to giving birth she kept
experiencing the same nightmare of
waking up on the beach Bridget seemed to
have caught wind of this and was able to
show her everything Lucy saw the beach
the birth of Sam the death stranding and
even more things we haven't talked about
yet and it practically broke her her
last note was addressed to Sam and it
talks about her taking her own life as
we know though suicide isn't that simple
in death straining and due to no one
finding her she caused the void out
which took the entire city Sam had
actually went to go see her at this time
as he wasn't able to get a hold of her
and he was caught in the blast once he
revived he saw the destruction which
broke him even more given the
circumstances of the death being a
suicide and the husband of the deceased
being the only Survivor Blaine was put
on Sam immediately and he was blamed for
the cause of the Void out Bridges was
under a lot of public pressure due to
this incident which led to Sam resigning
that's why he's a freelancer in the
intro he left Bridges but continued to
do his work under his own name and not
Bridges honestly given what happened I
can understand why Sam would hate the
UCA and would want nothing to do with
America at all but this is why Bibi is
called Lou as she's named after his late
daughter this is very clearly a deep and
traumatizing moment for Sam which is why
it's weird that dead man is so
comfortable which is blurting on his
business like that in any case it's nice
to be able to get some information for
once on Sam as it gives us a better
understanding as to why he initially
disliked the idea of reconnecting
America
shortly after this Hartman comes by and
asks if Sam can bring Mama's corpse to
his lab as her body doesn't necrotize so
he wants to see why just like all the
characters we've met so far Hartman is
another peculiar and unusual case
Harmon's unique Quirk is that he
purposely goes into cardiac arrest only
to be revived three minutes later a few
years ago Hartman was going to the
hospital for heart surgery his wife and
daughter were going to pay him a visit
but needed to stop home first on their
way home though they were caught in two
simultaneous void outs killing them both
Hartman wasn't caught in the blast but
the Shockwave knocked out the power
while he was on life support Hartman
along with all the other victims of the
Void outs were then sent to the beach
however the backup power kicked on and
sent Hartman back to the land of the
living just like how bridges use his
still mothers to replicate the first
sighting of the BTS Harmon replicated
the day he died in order to go back to
the beach and search for his family he
believes that if the beaches are
different then the afterlifes have a
chance to be different as well and he
wants to make sure he ends up in the
afterlife with his family when he dies
so he spends his days repeating this
cycle 21 minutes with the living three
minutes with the dead exploring the
various beaches of the world and hopes
that he finds their Beach he says he
makes about 60 trips to the beach a day
and is on cycle 218 549 meaning he's
been doing this every day for almost 10
years it's actually affected him so much
that the repeated shocks to his heart
have permanently changed the shape of
his heart to that of a drawn one hell
even the void outs create the same heart
shape I don't really get why it was
necessary to add that Last Detail but
the information is at least interesting
however unlike Mama we aren't able to
help Hartman Hartman has other plans for
us and even if we wanted to help him
this is his life now we aren't going to
be able to convince him to change he has
to do that himself Harmon during this
conversation says it's my damned Hearts
fault that we were torn apart but it's
also the reason I'll see them again
someday ironically it's Hartman's heart
that's the problem he can't accept that
he has to move on so he does this every
day just to be proved wrong each time
it's also very likely he'll never find
their Beach given how many people exist
the nature of the beaches are still very
confusing like whether or not a beach
still exists if that person passed on
and whether or not people outside the
U.S count as this game only focuses on
the stage but doesn't mention if the
broader world has been affected by this
too but hypothetically if we were to
assume on the low end that there's only
one million beaches Hartman's still
going to be doing that for at least
another 30 years at most there is a less
than one percent chance he actually
finds them which not only shows how
dedicated he is to achieving his goal
but also how deluded his mind has become
grief can be a hard thing to overcome
and everyone Grieves in their own way
but I hope we can all see how insane
this is Hartman's heart is the reason
he's alive but it's also the thing
that's killing him I can understand
where Hartman comes from as if this
theory is true which is surprisingly the
one theory he has that isn't a confirmed
fact and Hartman and his family will be
in separate afterlives then trying to
prevent that is important as they would
be separated for eternity otherwise but
still there's too many variables and
unknowns at play here that trying to
find the answer would be a worthless
Endeavor the world is cruel and bad
things happen to good people and Hartman
doesn't deserve what happened to him
which is why it sucks that of all the
people in this game he's the one we
can't help however Hartman doesn't seem
to mind he's been able to keep busy in
between those 21 minute intervals as
he's constantly working on Research into
the beach since he could visit the beach
more than any person he's become the
lead researcher on the beaches so even
if the beach he finds isn't his families
his discoveries can still prove useful
as such Hartman's instructions are to
deliver some packages to a few other
researchers it's once again more busy
work but the difference here is that
unlike our prior work these deliveries
contribute to research regarding the
beaches and the death stranding and
completing these deliveries will give us
more information about these topics it's
just like the oxytocin delivery it's a
set of quests that don't have a major
focus on one character but do progress
the narrative in a meaningful way before
we go though Hartman finds a small vial
in the bag we carried mama in which
contains an umbilical cord that looks
like a BT tether rather than an actual
cord it doesn't have any information
about it now but he might when we return
one thing I will say is that I like how
Hartman's condition was utilized during
this cutscene his 21 minutes are about
to be up when we talk to him so he has
us weight in his room while he goes to
the beach the game gives you enough
things to look at but it can be a very
boring three minutes plus you're right
in the middle of a conversation and
doing this shows the player how
interactions with him can be people
generally hate being interrupted and
this is what interacting with Hartman is
like as one minute he's awake and the
next he's gone this also happens again
later when Hartman collapses
mid-conversation which prompts Sam to
head out while he's asleep
continuing on though the information we
learned from the scientists is as
follows there were apparently deposits
of chirillium dating as far back as 65
million years ago meaning cairolium
didn't just appear recently furthermore
a species known as ammonite which is
dated to be about 200 million years old
had an umbilical cord attached to it
mammals are the only species that have
umbilical cords and we only use them for
Reproductive reasons so the species
having one is strange I know a lot of
that information seems forced and out of
nowhere but it does make sense in a
weird way the chiral network not only
allows people to share information with
one another but it also uses the beach
meaning we could use the beach to find
data about our world that's been lost to
time or the death stranding that's why
building the chiral network is so
critical as it provides us the means to
overcome the death stranding by giving
us all the information we had prior to
its events once we return to Hartman he
says he has a message for us from dead
man he says that the umbilical cord we
delivered was taken for Bridget's Strand
and that it was outside her body rather
than inside the cord like Mama's was
filled with chirillion meaning Bridget
had connection to the beach via the
umbilical cord but why was it on the
outside thanks to the info Hartman has a
developing theory that the five mass
extinctions occurred because of the
death stranding and that were in the
middle of the sixth one he further
states that the death straining occurs
because of a host called the extinction
entity each entity from the previous
five extinctions had an umbilical cord
attached to the outside of their body
despite the species not needing these
chords for anything with that
information laid out Harman thinks that
Amelie could be the sixth Extinction
entity once again I say Theory but he's
correct Hartman is almost always right
about everything now at the time this
really is a theory and we'll have to
wait to the end of the game to actually
get the answer but upon replaying the
game you'll notice how much of Hartman's
supposed theories are really just facts
it's nice to be able to get some
concrete info in a game where the
characters lie to you quite a bit but it
does feel out of place sometimes Harmon
goes from his talk about the extinction
right into what he calls this Extinction
entity Theory despite the fact that
we've never heard this word before plus
this isn't a theory it's just straight
up Canon fact because all of this is
real it's Kojima once again using
Hartman to relay truth about the game to
the player however I do have one genuine
question about this theory of his
Hartman states that the five extinctions
all had an Extinction entity these would
naturally be the ones leading the
species so when the dinosaurs were
reigning Supreme we can assume that the
extinction entity was a dinosaur and
that's where I'm lost I said earlier
that animals can't enter the beach but
Extinction entities require beaches in
order to enact the death stranding but
if all animals can't have beaches how
does the extinction entity have a beach
remember the beaches are a manifestation
of Humanity's perception of death which
means the beaches were created in Access
there were higher level of thinking
since we're sentient animals aren't
sentient and thus don't think about the
perception of death or any matter of
high-level cognitive thought so since
they can't how do they have beaches the
game is practically contradicting itself
here which is why I'm genuinely asking
if I miss something as I have read no
evidence that explains why my current
theory is that this is either a mistake
in the writing or that only the
extinction entities have beaches the
latter is a very loose Theory but it's
my attempt to make sense of it all more
important than that though is the
information about Amelie it is indeed
true that she is the extinction entity
for the six death stranding so we should
be careful around her and consider what
she plans to do with her power
with all that finished though we have
one more thing left to do before
reaching Edge not City figure out across
the tar belt that surrounds the city
this was admittedly a really cool puzzle
as it didn't hold your hand unlike most
of the game walking through the Tarbell
kills you and you can drive or launch
anything over it the only way to do it
is to intentionally get captured by a BT
once grabbed BTS will drag you to a more
spacious location set the bigger BTS can
spawn buildings in debris also spawn
since the tar is raising the objects
around it so by intentionally spawning a
boss fight we now have a way to cross
the tar belt parkouring across the
buildings though is a bit of a pain but
just in case you're like me and die the
resulting void out will give you enough
room to walk around the edge of the
crater to Edge not City even though it
took me a few minutes to solve I really
enjoy the out of box thinking required
to solve it Sam then sees Amelie near
the coast before falling into the tar
and waking up on the coast near Edge not
City so far in this video the ratio of
questions to answers has been about a
thousand to one so it's time to flip
that as the next few hours are all about
answers after going through quite a few
BTS we make it to Edge not city and have
officially reconnected all of America to
the Cardinal network but it's too early
to celebrate as once the network is
complete Higgs arrives to once again
ruin the day Amelie says that since
we've connected every knot together she
can now link all the beaches to hers
causing an Extinction far greater than
anything that's came before it this
isn't the sixth death stranding the one
of the many links in the chain this
would be the last stranding it would
completely decimate the land killing all
life and possibly the planet itself and
as the extinction entity it's her job to
bring about this destruction Higgs also
adds that the reason we have Dooms and
repatriation abilities is because of
Amelie since she's the extinction entity
she's the source of these powers
what follows is a lengthy boss fight
between Sam and one of the largest BTS
in the game once it's defeated though
the three reconvene again which leads to
Higgs shooting Sam and taking only to
the beach for what he calls the grand
finale to get there though we're gonna
need fragile who once again reminds Sam
to uphold his part of the deal to feed
Higgs but leave him alive fragile then
plans to jump Sam into Amelie's Beach
using his dream catcher and then using
her bracelet to bring herself to Sam
this necklace is given quite a bit of
attention throughout the game along with
this kipu that Sam made for Amelie it's
learned that if you have a strong
connection to someone then you can visit
their Beach I don't know if there's a
proper word for this but think of these
objects as things that hold significance
to these people which is why they can
use it to find that person's beach now I
want to clarify that the beaches still
behaved normally so it's not like Sam
can hold the dream catcher and then just
magically appear on the beach he has to
be taken there by someone who can like
fragile but the Dreamcatcher can help
him find the specific Beach easier as
it's connected to Amelie this concept
reappears shortly using a baby doll so
keep this in mind but the plan ends up
working and Sam makes it to the beach
things look strange though is not only
is Amelie confused as to why Sam is here
but Higgs is Bowing in front of her
despite the fact that he's supposed to
be her captor before he's caught though
he suspends her in a web of tar and
tells Sam that his goal has been to keep
the extinction entity safe according to
Higgs Humanity has about a few thousand
years before we all go extinct so why
not cut to the Chase and go out with a
bang Sam refuses to let that happen and
Higgs won't let Sam win and so begins a
good old-fashioned boss I'll just let
Higgs say it
in this place
[__] beach
there's no repatriation here no
one of us dies that's it
he goes to the other side
huh lucky loser just to put him into
this rinse repeat oh [__] once so
no BTS no void out no [__]
just a good old-fashioned boss fight
stick versus rule done versus strand
one more inning before the end
one last
I think out of all the roles Troy Baker
has ever done Higgs might be my favorite
of them all while I liked his role as
Joel In The Last of Us I've always found
him to play a fantastic villain he is
the actor who voiced Pagan Min after all
Higgs is an incredible villain from his
character designed to his charismatic
fourth wall breaking he's one of those
characters you just love to hate but
keeping in line with the whole getting
answers thing Higgs says that he's a
repatriot we don't get to see him
repatriating games so we can't tell if
he's lying but it doesn't matter anyway
as if one of them dies they can't go
back repatriation allows someone's soul
to go back to the land of the living
however Sam and Higgs are past that
plane of existence since they're on the
beach and repatriation prevents you from
going to the beach so Higgs is telling
the truth here but this discovery brings
up an interesting point we're so close
to the end of the game and yet we don't
really know a whole lot about Higgs well
if you manage to do a specific side
quest then you might know a bit more
than you think early in the game we get
a delivery order for pizza this is a
part of the main quest section of orders
yet feels like a side quest these are
some of my favorite quests in all of
video games as their side quests that
are given main quest priority for some
reason which means there's something
going on here and sure enough there is
the order is from a Peter Englert and
just like with Higgs unless you have a
degree in physics you likely won't catch
the connection Peter Englert is a
combination of two names Peter Higgs and
Francis Englert who won the Nobel Peace
Prize for the discovery of the Higgs
mechanism if you've noticed the
connection then you're catching on as
Peter is actually Higgs which is not
only hilarious as he's basically forcing
Sam to travel across the country to
deliver him pizza but it's also rather
creepy as inside his house is various
pictures of Sam at different points in
the game Higgs has been stalking salmon
by extension us throughout the game
which is a very unsettling feeling on
his desk though are some journal entries
that are written by him for us to read
but these are only a fraction of the
total amount there are 28 different
journal entries that are written by
Higgs which give us an understanding of
the world from his point of view the
first nine entries are about higgs's
early life as a porter surprisingly he
used to do it for survival since he had
a rough home life but over time he
started to do it for the sake of it he
was a real tried and true altruist and
loved helping people fragile Express and
ended up hearing about higgs's
accomplishments and that he had Dooms so
they recruited him to their outfit
that's when he would meet fragile and
the two worked as a team this also seems
to be around the same time Higgs
developed a hatred for Bridges one of
the other side missions we can do is
only available in the director's cut and
it has to do with a woman named coffin
coffin is fragile's Mother and just like
her dad they were Porters who did
deliveries for Bridges coffin would
renounce her contract with them though
once she discovered that the cargo she
was carrying were BBS she then worked
together with a ragtai group of Porters
to bring down Bridges and among their
ranks was Higgs now at the time Higgs
was using his Peter persona but she
cared deeply for him and sympathized
with his tragic upbringing eventually
though coffin would end up passing away
as their final mission was to assault
the facility we entered to complete the
mission inside his various objects that
are used by the stillmother's bridges
has the facility was then overrun but
Bridges managed to cover up their
involvement by blowing up the facility
and locking it away one by one the
members would die with coffin being the
last her final message was for Higgs and
it was for him to continue her Legacy
and not let the flame die out it's
unclear if Higgs managed to find this
message since the facility is locked
from the inside but it seems to work
anyway as the homo demons are likely his
attempt at keeping that flame alive
the timeline for Higgs is very confusing
especially since the missions with
coffin were added after the game's
release but it seems like all of this
happened before he met fragile assuming
that's true Higgs would eventually meet
fragile or coffin's daughter and the two
would work as a team under fragile
Express but as we know he would end up
betraying her his betrayal was due to
him meeting Amelie who would twist his
world upside down he like Lucy was shown
images of the beach and the death
stranding and realized what's the point
if the world is going to die why even
bother trying that's why he joined up
with Amelie to make the extinction
happen the thing is though is that
Amelie doesn't seem to want this to
happen the last few entries of his
journal are related to the present day
events such as entry 17 that talks about
salmon fragile arriving in Port not city
which is when we had to fight that squid
BT earlier but entry 18 says that Amelie
seems to be rejecting her true nature
and delaying the death stranding and
this is indeed true Amelie is a bit of a
complex case because she's both trying
to and not trying to destroy the world
she doesn't want to but the universe is
forcing her as that's the role she was
given at Birth her only purpose in life
is to bring about the death stranding so
refusing to do so would be going against
her entire reason for existing circling
back to the start of that entry though
Higgs is trying to enact the last
stranding as to him the world is doomed
anyway so why not end it on our own
terms there's a common saying you may
have heard of and that's life has no
meaning this is often used in nihilistic
circles as a way to say that life has no
meaning so what's the point anymore but
this can also be twisted in a more
positive meaning such as life has no
meaning until you give it one since life
has no meaning it's up to you to Define
what that meaning is or in another way
thanks to life having no predetermined
meaning we're able to make our own Higgs
and Sam are the two sides of this
meaning one sees no point in continuing
because of the odds while the other
wants to keep going despite those odds
this also connects to what Higgs says in
the beginning of the fight regarding the
stick vs rope and the gun vs strand the
very first thing we see when starting
the game is a quote about the stick in
the rope and how these were the first
two objects that man used the stick to
keep things away and the Rope to bring
them closer Higgs is the stick Sam is
the Rope Higgs is pushing people away to
make sure Amelie fulfills her purpose
and Sam is bringing people together via
the chiral Network that is what this
fight is all about who will prevail the
stick or the Rope the fight with Higgs
requires us to use the cargo left on the
beach as a weapon to distract him so we
can get in closer this is also the
moment that sparked that hole this game
feels like a game comment I said in the
intro as the final fight is a full-on
street fighter style matchup fit with
health bars light attacks and Dodges
sadly there isn't any combos in the
traditional sense you're really just
playing footsies and fighting from
neutral the whole time but it was fun
and is the kind of absurdity you expect
from games only video games are able to
pull this off and not immediately
provoke some side eye from the audience
it's still incredibly out of place here
in death stranding but that goes back to
the hole that's just so Kojima comment
death stranding is an incredibly serious
game about a very serious topic but at
its core it's still a game which is why
there is references to grinding boss
fights and game overs this does create a
weird imbalance as you're supposed to
take the game seriously but there's
times in its contents are complete
parody like the whole Metal Gear Solid
game over screen in the background but I
found that it was not only in good fun
but it never took away from the overall
message as right after this fight the
game goes back to Serious mode and
showcases another Core theme of the game
once Higgs is defeated something happens
he talks up a big game about how his
bond between Amelie is made of stronger
stuff before realizing his powers are
gone his Dooms were never his to begin
with they were always Amelie so he never
had real power without her higgs's
descent from altruistic Porter to
egotistical terrorist is fascinating to
see unfold as it connects to the idea of
hiding behind a mask the game has placed
a major importance on higgs's mask and
not just visually but more symbolically
masks are used quite a bit throughout
the game mainly with die Hardman Higgs
and Amelie for Higgs The Mask represents
his ego with the mask he's Higgs The
Fearsome terrorist without it he's Higgs
the porter the mask is a representation
of his ego thanks to him letting the
powers he got go to his head we can even
see this during the second part of the
boss fight where he goes ugh I could
beat you as if he's hyping himself up
since he knows he's losing Higgs is
nothing without these powers and he'd
forgotten that along the way the mask is
also ordained in this gold color so as
to stand out amongst the others further
reinforcing how far his ego has gone for
Amelie it's a representation of her
Extinction entity Persona every time we
talk with her she isn't wearing it and
these talks are about encouraging Sam to
keep going once she wears the mask
though she starts spouting out nonsense
about the last stranding whereas a mask
is used to hide the wearer's true
appearance with Amelie it's the opposite
but as I said it's complicated since she
doesn't want to enact the last stranding
but she also doesn't have a choice as
for die Hardman well we'll get to him
soon but it's clear that this mask of
his is also hiding something Sam anomaly
then talk for a bit and probably the
worst line in the game is spoken amili
tells Sam that she managed to visit him
at one point during one of their many
Talks meaning she was never captured and
could have just left at any point she
did this because Sam doesn't care about
the UCA or America and thus wouldn't
have gone on this journey if it didn't
involve Amelie Sam then replies so what
I'm Mario and you're a Princess Peach to
which Amelie says I know I know but it
worked out so let's run home together
like Mario and Princess Beach I don't
know if I should laugh at this line or
be genuinely disappointed by it
especially because the game fully
commits to this bit by having the two
run along the shore like it's the climax
of romance novel it's the most out of
place scene in the whole game but I
think that's intentional this came right
after the end of the final boss so my
thinking is that Kojima put this here as
a sort of subversion
the last 20 minutes has this weird video
game ending kind of feeling where we
defeat the big bad or rescue the girl
and go home that's why I found the
health bars to not be too distracting as
it fits what happens after you've
grinded for hours and built up your
arsenal of weapons and skills in order
to defeat the big boss in an
over-the-top boss fight the fight to end
all fights the finale the climactic end
to the game and then once you win you're
rewarded with the girl you spend hours
desperately trying to save and the two
you walk off into the sunset like I said
it's a very traditional video game style
ending but death stranding is not a
traditional game which is why the game
is not done after this supposed ending
I'd argue we're just getting started as
right when they stop Amelie disappears
and Bridget and Die Hard Men appear
nearby die Hardman has a gun to bridge
it and shoots her but the bullets go
through her shortly after a cliff
appears and die Hardman is shocked at
seeing him Cliff then asks Bridget where
Bibi is who then points to Sam Amelie
reappears and pushes Sam off the cliff
which somehow sends him back to the land
of the living
I'll get to that whole Fiasco later so
for now let's just focus on the present
Sam is back at the safe house that was
located near the tar belt we crossed
earlier dead man is also here via
hologram and says that both him fragile
Hartman and Mama are all here at the
Capitol not City the problem is that
fragile can't jump us to the city since
she's already used her powers too many
times we saw this much earlier when she
started bleeding after teleporting too
much but now she seems to be in a much
worse state which means we have to go
from here all the way back to the
beginning of the game it's the longest
and most dangerous Trek by far as the
chiral density has increased so BTS have
increased in number and simply entering
a Zone will cause a boss fight to start
once we reach the port we get the final
fight with cliff and everything goes as
expected except defeating him has a
different ending instead of cliff and
Sam fighting over Lou again he gives up
he realizes that Bibi was in front of
him all long dead man said that Sam and
Lou's memories were mixing and what we
were seeing were From bibi's perspective
but this is false these are Sam's
memories Sam is not only a former Bridge
baby but also Cliff's son Sam doesn't
understand it just yet but he will in
time for now cliff and Sam hug as Father
and Son something Cliff have been
wanting to do this whole time it's such
a captivating and a tear-jerking scene
seeing these two actors act in such a
believable way his father and son was
incredible right after this Sam wakes up
in another safe house and dead man plays
in a recording of die Hardman who says
that Bridget had invited him to her
Beach which is how he got there earlier
he knew it was a trap though which is
why he made this recording and he states
that when he became the director of
bridges he used his access to look at
some protected files in the company
archives and within them he discovered
that Bridget had during cancer in her
20s meaning she couldn't have had
children yet somehow she gave birth to
Amelie this is like one of those we've
never seen Amalie and Bridget in the
same room before so they must be the
same person except this is actually real
Amelie and Bridget are the same person
Bridget is the body Amelie is the soul
the heart and the car that's why Sam
only met Amelie on the beach and why she
could only ever be talked to Via
hologram because she wasn't real to
begin with this Extinction entity has
two names Bridget and Amelie they are
one in the same Bridget covered for her
other half by saying that Amelie was her
daughter and that she had a condition
that made her not age Bridget was the
body and thus the body Ages which is why
she ages Amelie is the soul and souls
don't age which is why she never aged
the game also teases this during their
princess beach scene as once Amelie
appears again you'll notice that Bridget
is no longer on the shore the same is
when Bridget appears right when Amelie
disappears this completely changes the
story of death straining but we still
have more to discuss the final leg of
this journey has us fighting a giant BT
whale the largest Boss by far in both
sides and health Amelie is getting close
to enacting the last stranding which is
causing the world to go into chaos so it
makes sense why the largest BT is still
waiting for us I also like the detail of
it being a whale of All Creatures too
after it's defeated we visit fragile
who's looking quite bad thankfully she
musters up enough strength to send Sam
to Amelie's beach before that happens
though Sam says his speech to the group
which talks about rebuilding what we
lost and that even though death is
inevitable we gotta keep going as long
as we can so we can say we had a good
run he also goes on to say that before
he only cared about seeing the next
sunrise but now that he's met them they
helped them change his outlook on life
Sam has shown genuine growth over the
course of this game and has become less
pessimistic about his life whereas Higgs
went One Direction in regards to his
character Arc Sam went the other he's
gone from a lonely Porter to someone
with friends friends who showed him the
true beauty of life and how just
building one connection with someone can
change your life it's just overall such
a great speech with an equally great
message Sam will then appear on Amelie's
Beach and hers is much different than
any of the beaches we've ever gone to
kind of wish the whole area wasn't
covered in fog though because the Earth
in the background is a real sight to
behold if you screwed the photo mode
settings
salmon Amelie then meet and talk she
presents Sam with two options and it now
or continue on knowing that the struggle
will be pointless she then hands Sam the
gun and tells him to choose she also
says that you should know what to do by
now and if you've gotten this far then
you should I feel like this message was
directed at the player rather than Sam
as death straining has told you since
the beginning that death is not the
answer no matter what which is why the
correct answer is to put away the gun
and embrace Amelie the last trending may
happen tomorrow next week next year or
next decade but that doesn't mean we
stop like I said life has no meaning
until you give it one just because the
world is going to end doesn't mean we
just drop what we're doing and accept it
we should instead live our lives to the
fullest knowing we had a good run
hugging it out and preventing the last
training temporarily is for the greater
good but we are going to be hurting
Amelie in the process she doesn't have a
beach she is the beach as such she can't
leave she'll be stuck here for however
long it takes to enact the last
stranding alone without anyone to speak
to but she knows this is the right
decision that if she has to suffer so
that everyone can survive then she'll do
it my favorite line of hers is at the
end when she says that the extinction
wasn't just an ending but an opportunity
the death straining has connected the
people of this world in ways that
wouldn't have been possible without it
they adapted in our attempt to overcome
the very thing that is trying to destroy
them by doing it together this is what
death straining is all about human
connection Embrace others rather than
push them away become the rope and not
the stick violence begets violence and
killing Amelie would have solved nothing
and letting her enact her own form of
violence wouldn't have either which is
why we have to stop this string of
hatred and death once and for all and
just accept each other regardless of who
they are even if that being was born to
kill the entire world Sam has a deep
love for Amelie which makes this
connection personal to him it's not just
about saving the world but also letting
someone he loves know that they aren't
alone and that'll always be there for
them even if they're stranded on the
beach for the rest of time the problem
is that doing this has now stranded Sam
on his own Beach and he can't return
after walking for what feels like an
eternity Sam attempts to kill himself
with a gun but it won't work Amelie
doesn't want Sam to end it nor does she
want him to feel lonely which is why she
brought cliff and him together
Amelie was the one who summoned cliff
into the world the World War era Beach
thing seems to be Cliff's own creation
but him being present in the world was
Amelie's doing she wanted Sam to know
that he was never alone and that he
needs to live and not throw away his
life oddly enough attempting to kill
himself was the key to saving it as
Hartman was able to track its use to the
beaches and find out where he was before
he leaves though we see the same five
entities we saw at the beginning of the
game it's never explained what these
individuals are but there are two
theories they are either the five
Extinction entities or the five friends
Sam has made along the way fragile dead
man Hartman die Hardman and Mama
personally I think it's both just as a
word's meaning may change over time so
too has this in the beginning these
entities represented death and were
meant to be feared it wouldn't be wrong
to assume that they were the extinction
entities but now that Sam has made new
friends and we the player have developed
connections to these individuals the
entities are now a representation of
Sam's friendships each of these five
people have built a bond with Sam and
his actions have changed their lives for
the better mama was able to move on and
reconnect with her sister dead man found
his first real friend Hartman didn't
exactly move on but we do get an email
after the game is over that says he has
stopped his search for their beaches and
his match someone new fragile has become
a lot more friendly and like Sam has a
more optimistic look towards the future
earlier I said fragile had ulterior
motives and it didn't mean for that to
come off as villainous it's just that
fragile never wanted to help with our
main objective of finding Amelie the
only reason she joined us is that it
just so happens that our objectives are
intertwined as finding Amelie also means
defeating Higgs you can tell that
fragile is happy to be of help to Sam
whenever you use the Fast Travel
mechanic you could see her smiling which
just shows that she's happy to help we
also learned after the game is over that
fragile restarted the business she's
back to doing what she wanted to do
before Higgs ruined it I've said that
fragile Express was her business but in
reality it was her late father's idea
the company was just named after her so
getting rid of Higgs and reconnecting
America gives her the chance to continue
her father's Last Wish
die Hardman is the only one I'm a bit
unsure of but to be fair he has been a
helping hand all game and reconnecting
America was his goal so in a way we did
help him with something but still each
one of these five entities can be seen
as the five friends we've grown to love
over the course of the game as Sam
approaches them dead man pulls him from
the bottom through the seam and back
into the land of the living time passes
and we see die Hardman giving a speech
to the us as the new president he and
all our friends have the same kipu Sam
made Amelie on their chest which
represents their bond and connection not
just to each other but to the whole
United States everyone is in the room
listening in Sam dead man Mama fragile
even Hartman but he's in the middle of a
beach trip everything has been answered
except for one question what started the
death stranding well the answer is Sam
the final mission in the game is to take
Lou to the incinerator as she's passed
her expiration date but dead man says
that Sam could take her out of the pot
if he wants to but it could kill her in
the process while at the incinerator we
see the full scene of those memories of
Cliff we've been seeing since the start
of the game Cliff Unger was visiting his
wife at the hospital when he was visited
by die Hardman he quickly shuts off the
cameras and tells Cliff to take Bibi and
get out of here Die Hard Men knew of the
BB experiments and didn't want his
former commanding officer to have their
son be used in BB Tech Cliff then shoots
his wife as this would be the last time
they would see each other and he doesn't
want her to be a part of the experiments
as well afterward he took Sam who is
still in the BB pod and attempts to
escape bucket shot in the process while
he bleeds out he starts singing and
talking to Sam before the guards break
through the door die Hardman and Bridget
are also here with the latter ordering
the former to shoot him now that he's
taken Bibi out of his pod here we can
see the mask come into play again as
Bridget is wearing a mask to mask her
identity so no one can connect her to
the experiments going on here die
Hardman wears the mask because of what
happens next as Bridget pulls the
trigger for him killing cliff and Sam
with the same bullet in order to cover
up the story die Hardman would have to
fake his own death and change his name
whereas characters like Higgs is a mask
to hide their other persona for Die Hard
Men the mask was literal he needed to
hide his face and name from everyone so
that no one could find out what happened
here while die Hardman is still getting
over the death of his friend Bridget
attempts to revive the baby to no avail
and then gets sent to the beach next to
Amelie who then revives it by sending it
back through her Beast to the land of
the living that's how Sam gained his
doom and repatriate abilities but also
how the death straining started as this
opened the floodgates for all the BTS as
they used Amelie's Beach to go to the
land of the living to add to the Past
references that's why the baby doll is
so significant for Cliff and die Hardman
the baby doll represents Sam because for
Cliff that's his son and for die Hardman
that's when he shot Sam as a baby that's
why die Hardman was able to use the doll
to travel to Amelie's Beach like how Sam
uses his dream catcher to do the same
and why these dolls are on Cliff during
his introduction scenes Higgs also has
the doll in his BB pod inside of an
actual BB but I don't think there's a
strong connection between them as the
other two which now that I think about
it actually makes sense as they're just
working together and have no actual
connection the doll was used in a more
literal way to be a link to Amelie's
Beach whereas the doll for characters
like cliff and I Hardman had more
meaning atop its intended use further
reinforcing that what the two had was
just superficial Higgs just protected
her so that her purpose could be fully
realized he never cared about her in the
same way Sam cared for her the final
flashback is a meeting between Bridget
and die Hardman who decided to take Sam
out of the Pod since he no longer serves
his purpose as a BB this of course has a
chance to kill him but as we know he
survives and just like Sam Liu does the
same and survives as well this then
prompts Sam to remove his cufflinks and
set off into the unknown world with his
new daughter Lou even though Sam built
these connections with these people he
wants to leave them behind as he thinks
this new America has no place for him
seeing as there is a sequel coming I
would love to see where this goes and
why he decided to choose this but
regardless this scene finally brings us
to the end of death stranding for real
this time to repeat what I said when I
first did the credits wow death
straining may be a jumbled mess of a
story for 90 of its run time but it
comes together at the end in a nicely
wrapped package just about all the
burning questions the player will have
are answered and it makes for a rather
cohesive Story the game is riddled with
themes and messages all of which are
important one I haven't even talked
about yet as it was just shown towards
the end and that's the pistol
the same pistol that Bridget uses to
shoot cliff and Sam is presumably the
same when die Hardman uses to shoot
Bridget and the same when Amelie gives
to Sam when making his decision it's
quite interesting how the gun that
started the death stranding is also the
one that ends it now we don't physically
use the gun on Amelie of course but
having the gun in her hand is a reminder
that death is wrong in an industry where
death and violence are commonplace where
you can dismember your enemies in a
million different ways Kojima wanted to
make a game that's the opposite death
straining was unlike anything I've ever
played before and it's that key aspect
of the game that's going to stay in my
brain for the years to come a lot of
games these days feel the same
everything nowadays seems to be a
bloated open world game filled with
pointless filler to add run time it's
just boring and while some may see death
straining as a bad game I'd rather have
a bad game than a boring one because at
least I was conscious enough while
playing to recognize what I disliked
rather than just going through the
motions like some kind of zombie death
straining may not have been your cup of
tea which is a completely valid opinion
to have as the gameplay is not for
everyone and the story can not only be
difficult to to interpret but also
inconsistent as it comes off as both
intelligent and pretentious at the same
time but we should at least recognize
that in an industry that is flooded with
similar gameplay Concepts and mechanics
death straining was trying to be
different it may not be your cup of tea
but it sure as hell is mine it's a game
with a very meta-like narrative that
serves as a critique about our own world
and how things like violence actually
prevents peace rather than achieves it
and how social media is a blessing and a
curse the internet has made us more
connected than ever but sometimes it
feels like we're more disconnected than
ever even if we ignore the out of game
themes death stranding still has a
wonderful story filled with likable
characters in a great Central plot the
pacing is off at times in the heavy
Exposition can feel out of place but
overall I was pleased at my experience I
will admit though that this is not a
game for everyone there's a reason why
people say you either love it or hate it
as this game is not the same stuff we've
been subjected to so naturally it's
going to displease those that hate it
would really strike something in those
that connect with it it's different and
different doesn't always mean bad which
is black command games reshape in the
mold even if I wasn't a fan of the game
personally and death straining is one of
those games that reshaped the mold by
creating a style of gameplay that's
incredibly unique and a compelling
narrative about human connection and how
we should come together rather than
isolate ourselves in an industry filled
with sticks Kojima wanted to be the Rope
thanks for watching
if you enjoyed the video please be sure
to leave a like And subscribe for more
story analysis like this death straining
was truly an experience and I'm excited
to see what death straining 2 is about
Sam seems to be much older fragile has
smooth skin again Lou is also much older
and Higgs seems to have taken over
Amelie's body who for some reason is
built like Ryden there's a lot that
could happen with this game and I'll be
here patiently waiting for its arrival
as always thank you all for watching
today and I hope you enjoyed like And
subscribe if you're new and thinking to
my returning viewers coming back to
another video take care everyone
goodbye